Red Hat OpenShift is the enterprise
Kubernetes platform,
and with the latest version, OpenShift 4,
the platform has undergone significant improvements to developer experience,
automation, and the management of the platform itself.
But what exactly changed, and what do you need to know about OpenShift 4?
Let's get started.
So, OpenShift is Kubernetes at the core,
and with OpenShift 4, the platform is now driven by Operators.
Yes, this includes the services that support OpenShift,
as well as app services that are deployed by users like you.
This is significant.
So, we'll start with covering Operators.
Next, we'll jump into one of the first things users will notice in OpenShift 4
- that is, an improved developer experience.
And this comes with significant updates to the console.
And then finally we'll dive into some of the community-driven projects
that OpenShift has adopted into supported solutions.
Things like OpenShift Service Mesh and OpenShift Pipelines.
There's actually more but we'll touch on these two today.
Starting with Operators, essentially they
allow you to automate the lifecycle of
containers. Let's say I'm deploying a
simple front-end and back-end
application. Once I deploy all of them
into my cluster, I've got to manage all
the automation or on the config of
individual applications, but with an
Operator I can take a different approach.
By installing an Operator into a cluster
with OLM, or Operator Lifecycle Manager, I can enable new CRDs, or Custom Resource
Definitions. These CRDs allow me to
manage my application using custom
config files tailored from my
application. In addition, any automation
that I need can be built into the
operator itself. Essentially I've
extended the Kubernetes API to create
new custom resources that are tailored
to the resources that you regularly work
with. In OpenShift 4, the services that
make up OpenShift itself are actually
managed by Operators. This means we get
to take advantage of that same framework to easily do installation and upgrades
of OpenShift itself. Check out the
Operator SDK to create your own
Operators, or use the embedded Operator
Hub and OpenShift to start quickly
and with
existing solutions. Next let's talk about
one of the first things you'll notice in
the platform and that is an improved
developer experience starting from the
console.
The main thing you'll notice is a
different view for administrators and
developers. There's new dashboard
capabilities for streamlined deployment
of applications, whether you start with a
git repo, container image, or deployment
YAML. In addition, you'll get better
observability into the platform. For
example, there's an advanced view which
tracks everything happening in your
cluster. There's improved administration
of the cluster itself, with a new user
manage section as well. Lastly, let's
close with some of the community driven
projects that OpenShift is supporting. One
of them is going to be OpenShift
Pipelines with Tekton. Tekon is a
cloud native way to declare CI/CD
pipelines and it's based entirely on
Kubernetes. It starts with defining the
tasks that make up a CI/CD flow, which
actually run as pods in your cluster.
These make up a pipeline and that's able
to deploy applications into your cluster.
In OpenShift there's actually UI
integration between Tekton and OpenShift.
So, OpenShift Pipelines lets you
manage your CI/CD all in the dashboard.
The other community-driven project I
want to talk about is OpenShift
Service Mesh. This is based on Istio.
Imagine you have a number of services
that are dependent on one another, a
number of concerns arise in the
interaction between these services. How
do you actually manage these
interdependent complexities? Well instead
of managing them in the app itself, you
can take advantage of the Istio Control
Plane which uses "sidecars" to basically
help you control how these microservices connect with each other, how
they enforce policies, and then even
observe how they behave. That way the
capabilities rest on the control plane
rather than the apps themselves. Thanks
for joining me for this quick video overviewing some of the newest features in
OpenShift 4.
As always, if you like the
video or you have any comments, please
drop a like or a comment below. Be sure
to subscribe and stay tuned for more
videos like this in the future.